FISCAL REVIEW SUB COMMITTEE ONE
ON EDUCATION WILL COME TO ORDER.
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
OF A WITH THE EN. AND ALL OF
THE SENATORS ON THE SUB
COMMITTEE ARE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WITH ME ARE
SENATOR STATE MEN. AND ROSA LEE
C. O. TROUBLED WE ANTICIPATE NO
VOTES SO I'M NOT CALLING THE
ROLE I'M JUST NOTING THEIR
PRESENCE. THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR A REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. LASTED EVERY
YOU WISH TO BE WRECKED THAT YOU
USE TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
OF THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP
UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WANT TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON ME WHEN
YOU'RE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOUR READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
LIMITED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND BILL BE
FOR THOSE. INDIVIDUALS THAT
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY AT THIS
POINT I DID NOT SEE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM THAT. APPEARS TO BE
READY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
964-844-2916 THREE SIX FOUR.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE
FOUR. TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN SIX
FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO USE THE TELECONFERENCE
SYSTEM. AND HOW IT WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND GORE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
AGAIN. THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
CLEARLY HEAR YOU AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
YOUR DEVICE THAT YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNERS
HIS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LIKE TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS TO ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
AND TO THE HEARING. THIS IS THE
SECOND OF EIGHT HEARINGS OF OUR
REGULAR SUB COMMITTEE PROCESS.
TO HEAR THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND OTHER RELATED
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF SUB COMMITTEE
ONE. THESE HEARINGS WILL BE
LARGELY INFORMATIONAL DESIGNED
TO ALLOW FOR DISCUSSION OF
ISSUES AND TAKE FEEDBACK TO
INFORM ACTIONS WILL BE TAKEN
LATER IN THE SUB COMMITTEE
PROCESS IN APRIL OR MAY. AND IN
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL REVIEW
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
REGARDING THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. CSU INCLUDING BASE
FUNDING STUDENT SUPPORTS AND
SEVERAL OTHER PROPOSALS THE
AGENDA IS DETAILED AND WILL BE
AND RIGOROUSLY GOES THROUGH
EACH OF THESE ISSUES. EXCUSE ME
BUT THE OVER ALL SITUATION IS
BEST DESCRIBED IN THE SUMMARY
CHARTS THAT SHOWED THAT THERE
WAS A REDUCTION. IN THE PAST
YEAR- AND THE PROPOSED HERE HAS
IT GOING BACK UP BUT NOT TO THE
POINT OF THE REDUCTIONS THAT
WERE MADE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
HIT- AND SO BEFORE WE MEN AGAIN
LET ME ASK SENATORS MEN FOR
TROUBLED IF YOU HAVE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS SENATOR MEN.
IDEA THANK YOU VERY MUCH CARE.
AS A FORMER PROFESSOR MYSELF IN
THE UC SYSTEM I UNDERSTAND. AND
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE VERY
STRONGLY IN THE CSC'S MISSION
AS LAID OUT A MASTER PLAN. AT
THE CSU IS REALLY THE WORKHORSE
OF OUR HIGHER ED SYSTEM IS
HUGE- IT'S I BELIEVE THE
LARGEST HIGHER ED SYSTEM IN THE
WORLD. I AND IT'S A ENORMOUS
CONTRIBUTOR TO OUR WORKFORCE-
IT IS A DRIVER OF OUR ECONOMY
LOCALLY IN ORANGE COUNTY- AND
OF COURSE ACROSS THE STATE- IS
ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT AS FAR AS
THE WORK FORCE NEEDS THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN IN THE IMPACTS ON THE
LOCAL ECONOMY- SO I GUESS- TO
ECHO CHAIR LEONARD'S POINT-
YEAH THIS. THAT BUDGET ARE FLAT
OF OUR VALUES. OVER THE LONG
RUN WE HAVE- THE WAY THAT WE'VE
TREATED THE CSU'S AND NEGLECTED
THEM DOES NOT SPEAK WELL ABOUT
OUR STATE'S PRIVATIZATION OF
HIGHER EDUCATION- I AM ALSO
CONCERNED LIKE CHAIR LAYERED
ABOUT THE 10% CUT THIS YEAR'S
USED TOOK. IN LAST BUDGET CYCLE
I WANT TO BUDGET GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES RESTORE THIS TO
SOME DEGREE IT DOES NOT FULLY
RESTORE THE 10% CAT. EVEN AS
THE CSU'S FACE A COSTS AND-
DROPS IN REVENUES DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC- I APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR'S EMPHASIS ON LOWER
INCOME AND- FIRST TIME FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS-
BUT I AM INTERESTED IN LEARNING
MORE TODAY ABOUT WHY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
FULLY RESTORE THE TWO HUNDRED
NINETY NINE MILLION DOLLARS CUT
FROM THE PAST BUDGET CYCLE-
I'VE ALSO. LEARNED THAT THE C.
ISSUES HAVE SIGNIFICANT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE COSTS THAT
HAVE BEEN NEGLECTED OVER TIME-
CSU FULLERTON AND- WHICH IS THE
ONLY CSU IN ORANGE COUNTY HAS
HAD ONLY ONE NEW BUILDING BUILT
IN THE LAST THIRTY YEARS EVEN
AS THEIR ENROLLMENT HAS CLIMBED
60% OVER THAT SAME TIME FRAME-
THEY'RE CURRENTLY FACING THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN FOR MAINTENANCE NEEDS- AND
OF COURSE THERE INFRASTRUCTURE
IS AGING. FINALLY I WANT TO
ADDRESS THE TOPIC OF COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY WHICH IT MAY NOT
BE SOMETHING WE WANT TO TAKE ON
THIS YEAR- BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT I THINK THAT CONTENDS THAT.
HAS REAL IT WAS. AS PRESS
PROBLEM IN OUR STATE. I HOPE
WORK FOR THIS. ON A- THE GOING
FOR- AND I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE
DI<c.cyan>- TO ADDRESS THE EQUITY</c>
GAP IN HIGHER EDUCATION- SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING. YOUR
TESTIMONY LEARN MORE TODAY.
THANK YOU AND- JUST TO KEEP
PEOPLE FROM TEXTING SENATOR MEN
FOR FIVE WHAT WE SAVE. THAT IT
IS THE LARGEST FOUR YEAR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN THE WORLD
AND FOR THOSE OF US THAT ARE
FORMER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRUSTEES THAT'S PROBABLY ONE OF
THE LARGEST HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEMS AND I JUST WANT. PEOPLE
TO NOT TEXT US AND BY MISTAKE
THERE I PAUL IT'S NOT A BAD
IDEA STAKE IT IS THE LARGEST
FOUR YEAR. HIGHER EDUCATION IN
THE COUNTRY. US SENATOR-
TROUBLE DO YOU HAVE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS. THIS TIME ABOUT THANK
YOU AND- WE WELCOME YOU TO THIS.
WILL HAPPY TO HAVE YOU HERE.
THEN WE WILL MOVE DIRECT TO
ISSUE ONE. WHICH IS ON THE BASE
BUDGET INCREASE ARE WE HAVE. A
BRAND OF BROWN'S FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RYAN
STORM FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM AND LISA.
QUINN YEAH M. PARDON. CAN WE
SECURING OUR PA LISA LISA FROM
THE WHITE AN OFFICE SAID WILL
TO THAT FOR SO IS SOBRE BROKE
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING MR MEMBERS RUNS THAT
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE
GOVERNMENT BUDGET IS A STUDENT
FOCUSED BUDGET WITH AN EMPHASIS
ON ACCESS EQUITY AND BUDGET
RESILIENCY. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
I'M GOING GENERAL FUND AND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATIONS. THIS INCLUDES A
3% BASED INCREASED HOLDING
TOTALING A HUNDRED ELEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
PLAN WITH THE FOLLOWING
EXPECTATIONS. THE
ADMINISTRATION EXPECTS THAT THE
CSU WELL MAINTAINED RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE TUITION AND FEES
AT CURRENT LEVELS FOR THE.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO ACADEMIC
YEAR. A REPORT I DON'T
ACTIONABLE WAYS SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE EQUITY GAPS WITHIN OF
FULL CLOSING EQUITY BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. I DON'T POLICY
THAT AT EXCUSE ME SIX. CAN
SUSTAIN ONLINE LEARNING PROGRAM
AT 10% OF US CODE LEVELS.
BETTER ONLINE STUDENT LEARN
OBJECT WITH WHERE FORCE. AND
FINALLY. ESTABLISHES DO AND
MISS PATHWAY TO THE- UPON. OF
LOWER DIVISION. HELLO CAN CALL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I DO
HAVE TO GO INTO FURTHER AS FOR.
OR ANSWER ANY YOU HAVE THANK
YOU VERY AND I THINK WE'LL OUT.
UNTIL THREE SPEAKERS THIS PANEL
SPOKE. SO WE WILL MOVE TO RYAN
STORM FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE A
FEW WORDS TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE UNIVERSITY BEFORE WE DELVE
INTO A NUMBER OF THESE ISSUES.
MY NAME IS RYAN STORM THE
SYSTEM VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
BUDGET FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR. WITH ME TODAY AND
ARE BY SAN JUAN SHE'S THE
ASSISTANT CHANCE FOR CAP PLAN
DESIGN. CONSTRUCTION AND MAKE
THAT HAPPEN SEIZE THE CHEAPEST
AND SENIOR ADVISER. FOR THE
ACADEMIC AND STUDENT AFFAIRS.
THREE OF US WILL PROVIDE YOU
THE DETAIL FROM- SEIZURES
PERSPECTIVE AND ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS TODAY. AND IT JUST A
LITTLE BIT AFTER MY INITIAL
COMMENTS I'D I WOULD BY MY
COLLEAGUE NATE AND EVENTS TO
SHARE A FEW THOUGHTS FROM A
PROGRAMMATIC ACADEMIC
PERSPECTIVE. TO NEW MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE IS MAY
MENTIONED- JUST A KITCHEN YOU A
BIT BETTER AND TO SHARE SOME OF
THE VERY HIGH LEVEL-
INFORMATION ABOUT THE C. I. YOU
ARE CORRECT BOTH OF YOU. THE
CSU IS A LARGE FOR. UP YOU. IN
COUNTRY AND THE CITY SHOULD
PROVIDE AS EDUCATION. TO
HUNDRED EIGHT SIX. STUDENTS ON
TWENTY THREE CAMP. THIS CAMPUS
STRETCH FROM A WILL. YOU IN THE-
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO DIEGO. YOU
AND. THIS ISSUE IN A LIKE A
CURSOR ONE HOW 27000 DEGREES
INFO NEAR THREE EIGHT NO LIVING
ALUMNI. NOW DO YOU NEW THESE
OTHER ARE PRETTY. MIGHT BE IF
ASK ME BUT NEARLY HALF OF ALL.
THE BACHELOR DEGREES A WAR AND
ARE C. ISSUE DEGREES. AND ONE
IN TEN K. WORKERS THIS USED
GRADUATE. AND IN FACT ONE INTO
AMERICANS A CALL DEGREE. FROM
THE S. C. ISSUE. NOT LIKE TO
SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE-
OVERALL CALM ABOUT THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL GOVERNOR NUISANCE FOR
THIS YEAR'S YOU RECOGNIZE THE
POWERFUL ROLE ARE CLAIM STATE
AFTER WE- YEAH THIS ISSUE STATE
READY TO DO. MORE IN RECALL THE
GO AND THE- SUPPORT AND JUST
FUNDING THAT WOULD RESTORE.
PRIOR CUTS CREATE JOBS INTEREST
INVESTMENTS AND ENSURE WE CAN
TO REDUCE GET IN PREPARES TO
FOR K. DIVERSE WORK. YEAH ISSUE
IS EXPERIENCING BUDGETS AS A
RESULT OF THAT ONE OF THAT TWO
HUNDRED NINE NINE BILL DOLLAR
I'M GOING BUDGET CUTS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. WE ARE ONE OF THE
VERY STATE PROGRAMS THAT
RECEIVED A NINE CUT THIS. AND
THAT IS NOT ALL ARE STILL
FUNDED STAY ENTERPRISE PRO ARE.
SUCH AS STUDENT. PARKING AND
DINING. THEY HAVE REVENUE. IN
EXCEEDS HUNDRED DOLLAR SINCE OF
THE PANDEMIC. WELL AS A BEACON
OF SO MOBILITY IN SHOCKING JOBS.
THERE ARE THREE AREAS WERE WE
ASK FOR IT AND- FIRST REST OF
THE CUTS MAINTAIN OUR JOB. THIS
ISSUE HS LARGE BEEN ABLE
VOIGTS WHERE AUSTIN CARRILLO OF
ITS THREE. FACULTY AND-
THROUGHPUT THROUGH FISCAL IN
USE OF RESERVES. WE WILL NOT BE
A TO DO THIS TERM REST. OF
STATE FUNDING. SECOND
GRADUATION IS SHIPPED TWO FIVE-
IS NEEDED. WE AT. THIS IS FOR
EVEN MORE TO WORK. ISSUE
IMPROVED. ITS YOUR GREAT RATE
BY SIX THREE. SINCE TWO SIXTEEN
THAT'S FROM A 19% RATE TO
THIRTY ONE PERCENT. WELL THAT'S
A SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHMENT
AND UNPARALLELED RETURN ON YOUR
INVESTMENT. BUT OUR WORK IS NOT
FINISHED AND WE ARE AND WE MUST
ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS. THIRD
PIECES ACADEMIC. AND
INFRASTRUCTURE CREATE JOBS NOW
THIS YEAR SHE WAS IDENTIFIED
SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ACADEMIC FACILITIES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
INCLUDING FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS APPROVED
PROJECTS THAT CAN IMMEDIATELY
PROCEED TO DESIGN AND OR
CONSTRUCTION TO HELP STIMULATE
THE ECONOMY. WHEN I KNOW THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
ONCE HAPPENS THERE SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT. SO IN
CONCLUSION THIS IS THE. THIS IS
THE CSU FUN REQUEST. TO NUMBERS
I ASK THAT YOU REMEMBER. FIRST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO
GOVERNOR INCREASES USE YOU
BUDGET FIND ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDING. THAT WILL
FULLY FUND THE GRADUATION IS
SHIPPED TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
REQUEST. AND FULLY RESTORE
PRIOR CUTS TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN DO THE MOST WE CAN'T TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE RESILIENCY.
THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND OUR
STUDENTS FUTURE. SECOND THAT IS
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE MILLION IN A ONE
TIME DOLLARS. ACADEMIC
FACILITIES INTERNAL NEEDS. AND
I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE MY
COLLEAGUE NATHAN EVANS TO SHARE
A FEW THOUGHTS. THANK YOU
MISTER STORM AND GOOD MORNING
SENATORS I AM NATHAN EVANS-
CHIEF OF STAFF AND SENIOR
ADVISER FOR ACADEMIC AND
STUDENT AFFAIRS AT THE CSU
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR- THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TODAY. A COUPLE COMMENTS I
WANTED TO SHARE SPECIFICALLY
REGARDING OUR WORK TOWARD
STUDENT SUCCESS- THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC CHANCELLOR EMERITUS
WHITE AND NOW CHANCER CASTRO.
HAVE KEPT THE UNIVERSITY SITES
ON TO NORTH STARS ONE
SAFEGUARDING THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF THE ENTIRE C.
ISSUE COMMUNITY. AND TO
ENSURING THAT AS MANY STUDENTS
AS POSSIBLE STAY ON TRACK TO
EARNING A PROVEN LOOK THE
PROVEN LIFELONG BENEFITS OF THE
CSU DEGREE. WE PLEDGE TO HOLD
HOLD FIRM OUR COMMITMENT TO
STUDENT SUCCESS IN EQUITY
THROUGH GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND HAS
BEEN CHáVEZ HAS BEEN SHARED WE
ARE DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE OF
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S FUNDING
PROPOSAL RECOGNIZING THE ROLE
OF HIGHER EDUCATION. AND THE
CSU SPECIFICALLY THAT WE PLAY
IN THE STATE'S ECNOMIC
RECOVERY IN THE LONG TERM
SOCIAL MOBILITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION. THE PANDEMIC PAST
MAY NEARLY ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND CSU STUDENTS EARNED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND JOIN THE
RANKS OF R. TWENTY THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION ALUMNI. THAT WAS
A RECORD NUMBER OF DEGREES
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL GRADUATES COMPARED
TO TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
YEAR BEFORE A GRADUATION
INITIATIVE LAUNCHED. AND WALL
COLLECTIVELY UNIVERSITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE SEEN
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT
DROPPED BY APPROXIMATELY 4% IN
THE LAST YEAR. OUR ENROLLMENT
IS A RECORD HIGH THIS ACADEMIC
YEAR WE ARE PROUDLY EDUCATING
THE LARGEST STUDENT BODY IN THE
C. ISSUES HISTORY. AND FALL
TWENTY TWENTY THAT STARTED
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS. AND PERHAPS
MOST NOTABLY DURING THE COVERT
PAT- NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE
RECORDED OUR HIGHEST RETENTION
RATE EVER WITH MORE THAN 85% OF
OUR FIRST YEAR STUDENTS
RETURNING TO CAMPUS AND FALL
TWENTY TWENTY. FOR THEIR SECOND
YEAR. AND THAT'S A TESTAMENT
NOT ONLY TO OUR STUDENTS TO NOW
CITY BUT ALSO THEIR TRUST AND
THEIR FAMILIES TRUST IN US TO
ENSURE THEIR PROGRESS TOWARD A
HIGH QUALITY DEGREE. THE THOSE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HAVEN'T
HAPPENED JUST BY HAPPENSTANCE
THIS ISSUE IS SUCCEEDING
BECAUSE OF OUR UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT TO GRADUATION
INITIATIVE. FOCUSED ON THREE
OBJECTIVES IMPROVING GRADUATION
RATES FOR ALL STUDENTS
ELIMINATING EQUITY GAPS AND
MEETING CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
NEEDS. BUT AS MR STORM NOTED
OUR WORK IS UNFINISHED IN DOING
OUR PART FOR A CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL WE MUST ELIMINATE EQUITY
GAPS BY RACE BY INCOME. AND BY
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE. WITH SOCIAL UNREST
AND ECONOMIC UPHEAVAL THAT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A MORE
IMPORTANT AREA OF INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- MISTER
STORMED A SECOND CSU'S PRO. YES
IT DOES SENATOR- WE WILL INVITE
A BY SAID ONCE THAT OFFER
COMMENTS- DURING ISSUE NUMBER
THREE OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THEN WILL MOVE TO LISA KING
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING CHEN SENATORS SIX KING
FOR ANALYST'S OFFICE DREAM THIS
MORNING BY MY COLLEGE CAL. OUR
OFFICE OF THE HER AND COMPANIES
NAY UNIVERSE BUDGET PROPOSAL. I
BELIEVE SENATORS RECEIVE A COPY
OTHERS CAN FIND IT ON OUR
WEBSITE. YOU'RE FREE TO JUST A
FEW OF THE FIGURES I PRISON
THIS MORNING. MY COLLEAGUES
SUMMARIZE THE FISCAL IMPACT THE
PANDA COMING INTO. INCLUDING
THE STATE REDUCTION AS WELL AS
STRUCK. PRIMARILY IN NON SOFT
PRO SUCH AS HOUSING PART.
TRODDEN CONTEXT IN SHARED CSU
TAKEN IN A BACK AMHERST TO THE
FISCAL. SHE SAID ACCESS TO SOME
ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDS. WHICH
WE SUMMARIZE IN OUR REPORT ON
THREE FIGURE TO. THAT'S FUNDS
TOTAL OF ONE POINT FOUR BILL
ACROSS TO RUN. IN ADDITION
FIFTY HAS TAKEN TAX STRICT
CIRCUIT SPENDING IN RESPONSE
THE STATE BUT REDUCTION
PARTICULAR. FOR EXAMPLE THAT
INCLUDE SUSPEND. A LOT OF.
DURING THE CURRENT YEAR. THE
CAMPUS ARE PLAN TO DROUGHT I
RESERVES USER TIME THE. FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION FOR CERTAIN COSTS
RELATED TO RETIREE HEALTH AND
PENSION. AS NOTED IN THE
OPENING COMMONSENSE REFLECTS A
PARTIAL RESTORATION OF THE
CAPTAIN SAYS HE RECEIVED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. THIS AMOUNT WOULD
LIKELY LAST HIS HE TO COVER
CERTAIN BASIC COST INCREASES
INCLUDING BENEFITS FOR
EMPLOYEES AND RETIREES. AS WELL
AS MEET CERTAIN THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. BEYOND THAT IT
WOULD DELETE IT WOULD LEAVE
SOME PORTION OF FUNDS AVAILABLE
FOR OTHER COSTS SEVEN SEES HIS
CASE THAT COULD MEAN FOR
EXAMPLE RESUMING SOME HIRING ON
A TARGETED BASIS STOCK FOR OUR
COURSES ARE MORE STUDENT
SUPPORT UNDER ITS GRADUATION.
CHEFS ALL IN ALL WE THINK THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FUNDING
LEVEL IS A REASONABLE STARTING
PLAINTIFFS ATTENTIVE BOTH TO
UNIVERSITIES COSTS AS WELL AS
THE STATE'S. OPERATING DEFICIT.
HOWEVER YOU RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REVISIT THE EXACT
FUNDING LEVEL NAY ONCE IT HAS
AN UPDATE ON STATE REVENUES AND
THAT'S A BETTER SENSE OF HOW
MUCH OF AN ONGOING AUGMENTATION
IT CAN ACCOMMODATE. THE
FINANCES NOTED. IT'S THE
SUPPORT PROPOSAL DOES COME WITH
CERTAIN EXPECTATIONS. RELATING
TO EQUITY COUNTY ONLINE
EDUCATION DELUDE MISSIONS AMONG
OTHER FACTORS. IN GENERAL WE
THINK THAT WITH THESE
EXPECTATIONS THE GOVERNOR HAS
IDENTIFIED AREAS OF COMMON
CONCERN WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT THERE ARE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FIND EACH
PROPOSAL. STARTING WITH EQUITY
GAP WE THINK THAT THIS IS AN
AREAWHERE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. YOUR RECOMMENDED
TALKING THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
BACK MODIFYING EXISTING
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR CSU
SO THAT INCLUDES THE EQUITY GAP
METRICS THERE WOULD BE
IDENTIFIED BY THE SEGMENTS
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL. REGARDING
ONLINE EDUCATION WE SEE A
NUMBER OF POTENTIAL BENEFITS
RELATING BOTH TO STUDENT ACCESS
TO COURSE WORK AS WELL AS THE
SPACE UTILIZATION. HOWEVER A
CONCERNED THAT THE 10% THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE MAYBE AN
ARBITRARY GOAL. AND SO WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THAT 10%
INSTEAD REQUIRING THE SEGMENTS
INCLUDING CSU QUITE CERTAIN
BASELINE INFORMATION ON ONLINE
EDUCATION. WE THINK THAT
INFORMATION ALLOWED THE
LEGISLATURE TO FUTURE BUDGET
YEAR TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ABOUT HOW BEST TO
SUPPORT ONLINE EDUCATION ISN'T
BOARD. FINALLY REGARDING DEAL
EMISSIONS WE THINK THEIR
POTENTIAL BENEFITS OR DRAWBACKS
OF THIS PROPOSAL AS IT RELATES
TO THE STUDENT TRANSFER
EXPERIENCE IT REALLY JUST
DEPENDS ON HOW THE DETAILS OF
THIS PATHWAY STRUCTURED.
RECEIVE SOME OF THOSE DETAILS
AND TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
EARLIER THIS WEEK AND ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF. GETTING THEM
NOW. CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS IN
THIS FIRST AND LARGEST ISSUE
YOUR AGENDA THIS MORNING. I'M
JENNIFER AND I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE PRESENTATION AND-
LET ME JUST REMIND THOSE THAT
ARE WATCHING THAT. THE VERY
LAST ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS
PUBLIC COMMENT SO WILL NOT BE
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT AS WE GO
ALONG TO IT IN THE AGGREGATE
AFTER THE DIFFERENT
PRESENTATIONS. WELL LET ME LEAD
WITH A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND
FIRST. UP ON THIS ISSUE WOULD
BE DIRECTED TO THE TO THE FIRST
QUESTION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THEN I WAS GONNA ASK-
WHAT'S YOUR RATIONALE WAS FOR
NOT BACK FILLING THE BASE
REDUCTION TO THE- CSU SYSTEM.
SORRY BRIANNA BRANDS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO AS
INDICATED IN THE AGENDA AT THE
CSTO RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT-
ONGOING RESOURCES IN THE BUDGET
ACT. AS WELL AS ONE TIME
FUNDING THROUGH THAT THE
VARIOUS FEDERAL OR THESE BILLS
ENACTED BOTH IN TWENTY TWENTY.
TO TWENTY TWENTY THE MOST
RECENT OF WHICH- WAS. ENACTED
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY. I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SEEKS TO
ADDRESS- A NUMBER IT NEEDS
WITHOUT SIGNING THEM OUT OF
RESOURCES. THE ADMINISTRATION
REMAINS CONCERNED. ABOUT
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS IN THE OUT
YEARS. BUT IF. YOU'RE NOT
RESTORE THE BASE TO WHAT IT IS
THAN ANYTHING THAT THE FEDERAL
MONEY COMES FOR IS CHALLENGED
BY NOT COMING BACK IN THE BASE
THE AND THE OTHER ITEMS THAT
ARE IN THIS BUDGET ARE
CHALLENGED. IN THE BILL TO
DELIVER BY NOT COMING BACK TO
THE BASE IS THAT SOMETHING
AS YOU MOVE TOWARD THE MAY
REVISE. WE DEFINITELY
UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE'S
CONCERNS AND WILL DEFINITELY BE
TAKING THAT BACK TO OUR
LEADERSHIP TEAM. THANK YOU. AND
THEN LET ME ASK ONE QUESTION OF
CSU- I WAS GONNA ASK IF- YOUR
CONTEMPLATING ANY INCREASE IN
TUITION IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FOR THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. YEAH
RAINSTORM AGAIN- SENATOR- WE
ANNOUNCED THAT OUR MOST RECENT
BOARD OF TRUSTEES MEETING THAT
WE'VE ALL. NOT BE INCREASING I
TUITION FOR THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- PRINCIPALLY THAT'S
BECAUSE OF A NUMBER OF. IT BITS
OF GOOD NEWS OBVIOUSLY THERE IS
THAT THE ADDITIONAL INCREASE AT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
THAT'S HELPFUL ALSO THERE IS-
THE ADDITIONAL HELP FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON A ONE
TIME BASIS SO WE FEEL LIKE IN
THE SHORT TERM FOR THE FALL-
THAT'S THAT WE CAN TAKE IT OFF
THE TABLE IN THE TRANSFER ME TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS. OR JANUARY
MEETING UP FOR A FALL OF TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE'LL HAVE
TO SEE THAT WE MAKE THIS
DECISION ON A YEAR BY YEAR
BASIS DEPENDING ON. LARGELY
WHAT THE ANTICIPATED STATE
SUPPORT WILL BE. WE GENERALLY
EVERY YEAR SINCE. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. HAVE THE
PROCESS. STEPS PROCESS OUT
DELIVERING A TUITION. THE
STUDENTS EVERY FALL AND THEN WE
FOLLOW THAT. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAY PROCESS IS OUTLINED IN
STATUTE AND THEN AS WE GET TO A
CERTAIN COMFORT POINTS WE WILL
MAKE THAT DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER TO PURSUE TUITION. SAY
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO. BUT WE
ONLY RAISE TUITION ONCE IN THE
LAST DECADE- AND SO- WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE AT THIS POINT- IN
TERMS OF OUR TIMELINEOF DOING
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
IT'LL BE A TO BE DETERMINED FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
FOR THE ANSWER TO THE QUESTION
NOW WILL GO TO ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR
MEANT. THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY- I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN. FOR
CSU- THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
WHAT WAS YOUR RESEARCH BASIS IN
ESTABLISHING A NEW TRANSFER
PROCESS- YEAH DID YOU DO ANY
STUDY ON THIS WHAT ARE THE PROS
AND CONS THAT YOU ON COVERED.
AND ONE OF THE PRIORITIES ARE
POLICY GOALS YOU'RE YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE WITH THIS.
SHARKS THREE FRIENDS AGAIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO
REALLY I WOULD SAY THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE IS VERY
FOCUSED ON ACCESS AND EQUITY
AND SO WE SEE THAT ALL
EMISSIONS AND- PROPOSAL AS
INCREASING ACCESS- AND EASING
THE PROCESS. FOR TRANSFERRING
FOR STUDENTS. GOING INTO I CSU
OR UC- GOT IT ALTHOUGH I A DEAL
IT SEEMS LIKE. THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD NOT REALLY. TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE TWO YEARS OF ACTUAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PERFORMANCE
THAT WOULD PERSONALLY MATTER
BUT LET ME PUT THIS QUESTION TO
SEE IF YOU. HAVE YOU STUDY THIS
PROPOSAL YET AND WHAT DO YOU
SEE. AS YOUR PRELIMINARY- THAT
CONCERN OR- YOU KNOW IF IT'S A
OF THIS AT ONE OF THE- AND CONS
THAT YOU THINK MIGHT ACCOMPANY
THIS PROPOSAL. GOOD AFTER GOOD
MORNING AGAIN THIS IS NATHAN
EVANS FROM CSU- AS MISS KING
INDICATED EARLIER THE DETAILS
OF THE PROPOSAL ARE JUST
BEGINNING TO COME FORTH AND SO
WE'RE REALLY JUST BEGINNING TO
LOOK AT THOSE. I WOULD SAY THAT
IT- CONCEPTUALLY BUILDS ON A
VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM WHICH
IS THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER- WHICH IS HAS JUST
CELEBRATED ITS TENTH
ANNIVERSARY AND WE NOW SEE
THAT- QUICKLY BECOMING. THE
PRIMARY MECHANISM BY WHICH
STUDENTS TRANSFER FROM
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO THE CSU. I THINK AS WAS
NOTED- WE'RE WE'RE JUST REALLY
BEGINNING TO LOOK AT WHAT THOSE
DETAILS WOULD BE AND AS YOU
MENTIONED. IT'S DIFFICULT AT
THIS PINT TO FACTOR AND THEIR
EXPERIENCES STUDENTS WILL HAVE
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THAT
PROCESS I THINK CONCEPTUALLY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO FIND
WAYS. SO THAT STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES HAVE A CLEAR PATH AS
THEY EXIT HIGH SCHOOL VIA A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND HAVE. A
OF MORE- DEFINITIVE PLAN AS
THEY ENTER A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IN SETTING INSTEAD OF HAVING TO
SEEK THAT OUT. I THINK THERE
MAY BE OTHER WAYS THAT THAT
COULD BE ACHIEVED USING THE AT
T. AS A VEHICLE BUT AGAIN WILL
REALLY NEED TO SPEND TIME
REALLY LOOKING AT THE ELEMENTS
OF THE PROPOSAL. GOT IT- MY
SECOND QUESTION IS A ONE THAT
FOLLOWS UP ON CHAIRMAN
LEONARD'S- LINE FIRST LINE OF
QUESTIONING AROUND WHY NOT BACK
TO THE KIND I GUESS. MAYBE I
WANT TO POSIT IS IN A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT WAY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET STRONGLY EMPHASIZES K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS-
INCLUDING THE NEED TO REOPEN
THE LEARNING LOSS THAT THEY'RE
FACING RIGHT NOW FROM DISTANCE
LEARNING- I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS THIS- WE ALL I THINK. ASSUME
TODAY THAT HIGHER ED IS VERY
IMPORTANT- THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE TOLD THE CENTRAL YOU NEED A
HIGHER DEGREE TO GET A GOOD
JOB- ANGEL WHY DO WE NOT HAVE
THE SAME EMPHASIS ON HIGHER ED.
THAT WE DO FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE- ARE WE JUST BASICALLY
ST COLLEGE IS NOT AS IMPORTANT
AS AS K. THROUGH TWELVE IT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT SEEMS
LIKE FROM. THE THREE PERCENT.
OF THE TIME PERCENT BACKFILL-
WHERE IS YOU KNOW WE REALLY
EMPHASIZE K. THROUGH TWELVE
WITH THIS BUDGET AND SO I'D BE
INTERESTED IN HEARING THE
DEPARTMENT'S FINANCES THOUGHTS
ON THIS. YEAH CHRIS FOR YOU
SOME OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. CHAU OR K. FOURTEEN
BUDGET. WHICH IS BOTH ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS OUR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. IS
GENERALLY FUNDED ACCORDING TO.
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE WITH. A SPECIFIED
MINIMUM. EXPENDITURES FOR OUR-
FOURTEEN ENTITIES WHEREAS OUR
UNIVERSITIES ARE FUNDED THROUGH
A NON THE NONPROFIT'S MISSION
NINETY EIGHT A GENERAL FUND
SIDE OF THE BUDGET- SO
CERTAINLY WE ATTEMPT TO
BALANCE. THE NEEDS OF THE
SYSTEMS AGAINST- THE NEEDS OF
ALL PROGRAMS IN THE STATE WE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THAT THE
CONCERN OF THE COMMITTEE HAS
RAISED- AND ARE ACTIVELY YOU
KNOW LOOKING INTO THAT
PARTICULAR ASPECT- AS WE WORK
TOWARDS THE MAIN PROVISION.
KEEP FINALLY LAST QUESTION ON
MY END- YOU WOULD WITH THE ONE
OF THE PROPOSALS ARE WEATHER
CONDITIONS FOR THIS 3% BACK
FILL IS- I GUESS. INCREASE
ONLINE EDUCATION BY 10%
COMPARED TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY NINETEEN. HAS ANYONE
DONE WHETHER CSU OR THE PARTNER
FINANCING DONE- ANY KIND OF
STUDY ON THE EFFICACY OF THIS I
MEAN I AS A FORMER PROFESSOR WE
WERE ALWAYS TAUGHT THE IN
PERSON. AND I BELIEVE THE
RESURGENT CASES IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IS MORE EFFECTIVE
THAN ONLINE LEARNING- HOW DOES
THIS FIT IN THIS YEAR'S USE
PLANS AND WHAT AGAIN THE PROS
AND CONS OF THIS APPROACH.
PALACE ARE IN PART IN A
FINANCING TO BE INTERESTED TO
HEAR FROM THE CSU. CORRECT.
RENDON FINANCED- I'M I'M SAYING
IT AGAIN GOING BACK TO ACCESS
AND EQUITY THE FOCUS HERE- OF
THE ONLINE REQUIREMENT IT'S
REALLY JUST ENSURING THAT THE
CSU IS ABLE TO RETAIN SOME OF
THE ONLINE CAPACITY THAT THEY
HAD BUILD UP IN RESPONSE TO THE
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC- MEETING
THAT WE WOULD NOTE HERE THAT
ONLINE EDUCATION- WELL IT
REALLY HELPED EXPAND ACCESS
PARTICULARLY FOR STUDENTS- WHO
HAVE FAMILY OBLIGATIONS OR WORK
OBLIGATIONS AGAIN REALLY TRYING
TO FOCUS ON AND. THE ACCESS AND
EQUITY PIECE HERE. AND AGAIN
THIS IS DAVE EVANS WITH THE C.
AS- AND I WOULD AGREE WITH HIS
FRIENDS COMMENTS THAT I THINK
WELL WE'VE HEARD CHANCELLOR
CASTRO CERTAINLY. INDICATE THAT
HE BELIEVES THAT THERE IS
OPPORTUNITY AS WE EXIT THE
PANDEMIC AND LOOK TO THE
FUTURE. THAT ONLINE EDUCATION
CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE NEW
AVENUES OF ACCESS TO A VARIETY
OF STUDENT POPULATIONS. OUR
ACADEMIC LEADERSHIP ON OUR
CAMPUSES ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
THROUGH WHAT ARE THE PERHAPS
BEST CURRICULAR- HORROR
PARADOXICAL SETTINGS FOR ALL
FOR THE USE OF ONLINE EDUCATION
SO FOR EXAMPLE. FOR EXPONENTIAL
LEARNING THAT MIGHT BE LAB
BASED OR A FIELD BASED
CERTAINLY IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
IS A PREFERRED AND THE SOONER
THAT WE CAN MOVE BACK TO THAT
MODALITY. THE BETTER FOR
LEARNING AND FOR THE OUTCOMES
OF STUDENTS BUT THERE ARE
CERTAINLY FORMATS THAT WE
BELIEVE CAN BENEFIT FROM
INCREASED ONLINE INSTRUCTION
AND SO I THINK- WELL- CENTER
MENU MENTIONS SIR THE HISTORIC
RESEARCH IN SOME WAYS I THINK
THERE'S BEEN A NEW BASELINE
SET. AS WE AS NOT JUST THE
ISSUE BUT UNIVERSITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAVE WORKED THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC AND DONE A LOT OF
LEARNING OURSELVES AS
ORGANIZATIONS ABOUT ONLINE
INSTRUCTION- AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE WORK AT OUR CAMPUSES
ARE UNDERTAKING NOW
DETERMINING. WHAT ARE THE BEST
CURRICULAR OR PEDAGOGICAL
SETTINGS THAT ONLINE CAN BE THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL. TO PROVIDE
ANOTHER AVENUE OF ACCESS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATORS AND
ROADSHOW DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME OKAY
THEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ISSUE
TO FIVE STUDENT SUPPORTS AND
BASIC NEEDS AND IT IS THE SAME
THREE PANELISTS AND WE WILL BE
DO IT IN THE SAME QUARTER SO WE
WILL BEGIN WITH BROWN A BRONZE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
STUDENT SUPPORTS AND BASIC
NEEDS. ANDRIANA BENEFIT
APARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS A STUDENT
FOCUSED BUDGET WITH AN EMPHASIS
ON. ACCESS EQUITY AND BUDGETARY
RESILIENCY I HAVE BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED IN LIGHT OF THE CO
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC STUDENT
SUPPORTS AND BASIC NEEDS ARE
CRUCIAL TO ACADEMIC SUCCESS. TO
PROVIDE FURTHER SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS INVESTMENTS
FOCUSING ON ADDRESSING STUDENT
TECHNOLOGY AND MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS. FIFTEEN MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND FOR THE BASIC
NEEDS COMPONENT OF. THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THIRTY MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR EMERGENCY
FINANCIALLY ASSISTANCE AND
FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
SINCE THE SUSPENSION DATE FOR
SUMMER TERM FINANCIAL AID THERE
BY MAINTAINING THE PROGRAM AT
SIX MILLION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WILL HOLD
QUESTIONS UNTIL THE END OF WILL
GO TO BRAINSTORM NEXT FOR CSU.
ACTUALLY I WOULD I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN
ECONET AND SCAN- INITIALLY
RESPOND ON OUR BEHALF THANK YOU
THAT'S GREAT. HELLO THANK YOU
MISTER STORM AND CHAIR- AGAIN
NATHAN EVANS FROM THE C. ISSUE
AS PART OF GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
THIS THE ISSUE IS IDENTIFIED
SIX OPERATIONAL PRIORITIES TO
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT STDENT
SUCCESS AND SUPPORT ACROSS THE
C. ISSUES SYSTEM- THESE AREAS
WERE IDENTIFIED BOTH THROUGH
RESEARCH. AND PRACTICE AS
HAVING SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
DEGREE COMPLETION AND STUDENT
SUCCESS. THOSE SIX AREAS VERY
BRIEFLY OUR ACADEMIC
PREPARATION ENROLLMENT
MANAGEMENT STUDENT WELL BEING
AND BASIC NEEDS. FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. LEVERAGING DATA TO
INFORM DECISIONS AND
IDENTIFYING AND REMOVING
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS AND
THOSE PILLARS HAVE STOOD SINCE
THE INITIATIVE LAUNCH. WELL ALL
THOSE ARE IMPORTANT THERE'S
BEEN A RENEWED FOCUS ON
SUPPORTING STUDENTS WELL BEING
AND EXPANDING FINANCIAL SUPPORT
DURING THE PANDEMIC. CRITICAL
TO STUDENT SUCCESS THE BASIC
NEEDS INITIATIVE FOR EXAMPLE
TAKES A HOLISTIC LOOK AT
STUDENTS WELL BEING BOTH INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM FROM
HOUSING AND FOOD SECURITY TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND MOST RECENTLY
BRIDGING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
WITH THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC
AND ASSOCIATED NEGATIVE
FINANCIAL IMPACTS OUR CAMPUS IS
EXPERIENCED A DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN DEMAND FOR STUDENT BASIC
NEEDS SUPPORT WE ARE AGAIN
APPRECIABLE OF GOVERNOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOGNITION OF THESE
PRIORITIES THAT ARE SHARED BY
OUR STUDENTS OUR FACULTY STAFF
AND ADMINISTRATION. AND BASED
ON EXISTING WORK THIS ISSUE HAS
ALREADY ESTABLISHED AN
EFFECTVE PROCESS FOR SETTING
CLEAR CRITERIA FOR ELIGIBILITY
AND THEN SOLICITING AND
REVIEWING PROPOSALS. FROM OUR
CAMPUSES AND PROVIDING TRACKING
AND FISCAL WORDS- TO SUPPORT
CAMPUS BASED INITIATIVES AROUND
BASIC NEEDS AND MENTAL HEALTH.
SO FUNDING WOULD BE USED TO
SUPPORT THE FULL RANGE OF THESE
INITIATIVES FOOD INSECURITY AND
HUNGER HOUSING INSECURITY AND
HOMELESSNESS MENTAL HEALTH
CRISES EMERGENCY CRISIS FUNDING
PERSONAL SAFETY THREATS AND
DIGITAL LEARNING NEEDS. WE ALSO
SEE THIS IS A CONTEST AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
INCREASE PARTNERSHIP AND
COLLABORATION AS A AS OF THE
END OF FALL TWENTY ARE FULL
TWENTY TWENTY SEMESTER ALL
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES HAVE
ESTABLISHED AT LEAST ONE
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS OR
SERVICE PROVIDERS. TO DELIVER
DIRECT SUPPORT TO STUDENTS
PRIMARILY IN THE AREAS OF FOOD
ASSISTANCE TEMPORARY EMERGENCY
HOUSING AND MOST RECENTLY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. AND
FINALLY REGARDING EMERGENCY
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID- LAST
SUMMER THIS IS C. ISSUES
SUCCESSFULLY DISTRIBUTED TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO MILLION
AND DIRECT STUDENT AID AS PART
OF THE FEDERAL CARES ACT. WE
WOULD ANTICIPATE USING SIMILAR
APPROACH THE BENCHMARK STUDENT
AGAIN STUDENTS DOCUMENTED
FINANCIAL NEED AND AUGMENTED
THE FEDERAL DOLLARS WITH
PHILANTHROPIC OR OTHER
RESOURCES FOR STUDENTS WHO
CANNOT QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL
STUDENT AID. SO IN SOME WE ARE
PORTION OF AGAIN OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RECOGNITION OF
THIS CRITICAL AREA OF NEED. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION AROUND THAT TOPIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT NOW
WILL MOVE TO MEXICAN OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
OKAY OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
SURVEY DATA SUGGESTED THAT AND
NOTABLE SHARE OF STUDENTS AT
CSU AS WELL AS THE OTHER
SEGMENTS FACED CHALLENGES
MEETING CERTAIN BASIC NEEDS
PARTICULARLY SHOULDN'T HOUSING
AND DOESN'T START AT IT THERE
ARE SIGNS THESE CHALLENGES HAVE
BEEN EXACERBATED SINCE THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC. I THINK
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES AN IMPORTANT AND
TIMELY PROBLEM. IMMEDIATELY
REYES AND OUR REPORT IS THAT IT
CONTINUES AS SOME PIECEMEAL
APPROACH ADDRESSING BASIC NEEDS
THAT THE STATE HAS TAKEN OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS. STATION
OF THIS APPROACH ON PAGE
FIFTEEN OF DALIO'S REPORT IN
FIGURE NINE. THIS FIGURE
SUMMARIZES THE PROGRAMS
LEGISLATURE IS FUNDED RELATING
TO BASIC NEEDS SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. YOU'LL
NOTICE THAT THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT I COULD
HAVE OVERLAPPING GOALS FOR
EXAMPLE SHOULDN'T HOUSING
PROGRAM AS WELL AS A RAPID RE
HOUSING PROGRAM. MOREOVER
YOU'LL NOTICE THAT THERE'S SOME
INCONSISTENCIES IN HOW THE
STATE IS FUNDED BASIC NEEDS
ACROSS THE SEGMENTS COMPARING
YOU SEE TO SEE IF YOU FOR
EXAMPLE WE FEEL IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY THE STATE
PROVIDED ONGOING CONSTANCY FOR
FOOD HOUSING AND MENTAL HEALTH.
ALL PROVIDING ONE TIME FUNDS TO
SEE IF YOU FOR THE SAME PURPOSE
AS- WITH ALL THE CONTACTS IN
MIND WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE ENSURE THAT IF IT
IS GOING TO CREATE. TWO NEW ON
GOING BASIC NEEDS PROGRAMS AT
CSU. THAT THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE
CLEARLY DEFINED AND MEASURABLE
OBJECTIVES. AND MOREOVER THAT
THE PROGRAMS ARE COORDINATED
WITH EACH OTHER AS WELL AS THE
EXISTING INITIATIVES TO THE
STATE HAS IMPLEMENTED TODAY.
WHEN THERE'S OPPORTUNITY TO
COORDINATE THE ONE TIME FUNDS
FROM REGENCY FINANCIALLY IT
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR CSU.
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS CASE WE
THINK THERE'S OPPORTUNITY TO
COORDINATE THEM IN RELATION TO
THE FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS THAT
HAVE RECENTLY BECOME AVAILABLE
FOR VERY SIMILAR PURPOSE. THAT
COULD MEAN TARGETING THE STATE
FUNDING TOWARD STUDENTS ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY IT FUNDING. FOR ALL
GENTLY EIGHTEEN TIMING THE
STATE FUNDS SO THAT THEY
ARRIVED AFTER THE FEDERAL FUNDS
HAVE DRIED UP. LOOKING LONG
TERM IN THE BIGGER PICTURE.
LEGISLATURE ALSO CONSIDER
TAKING STEPS TOWARD DEVELOPING
A MORE HOLISTIC STRATEGY TOWARD
MEETING STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS
STEPPING AWAY FROM THE MORE
PIECEMEAL APPROACH THAT THAT
THE STATE HAS TAKEN OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS THIS WOULD OF
COURSE INVOLVES A JOINT EFFORT
WITH THE SEGMENTS OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND IT WOULD MEAN
ESTABLISHING OVER ARCHING
OBJECTIVES FOR THE STATE'S
BASIC NEEDS PROGRAMS. DURING
THE AMOUNT OF NEED FOR THESE
PROGRAMS AND COORDINATING THE
PROGRAMS NOT ONLY WITH EACH
OTHER AS WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
BUT ALSO WITH TRADITIONAL
FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
ALSO INTENDED TO HELP STUDENTS
MAKE THEIR LIVING EXPENSES. AS
WELL THE PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS PROGRAMS LIKE CALFRESH
THAT ARE INTENDED TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS IN GENERAL BUT
THIS TAX EXPENSES. THANK YOU
THE HOBBIT TAKING QUESTIONS
THANK. YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH. I HAVE A FEW- WITH.
THE AND THE FIRST ONE IS FOR
FINANCE. AND I WAS WONDERING IF
YOU COULD EXPLAIN THE RATIONALE
FOR COMBINING MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDS WITH TECHNOLOGY FUNDS.
YES CERTAINLY SO I THINK IT'S
BEEN MADE PRETTY AWARE THAT THE
COMING NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS
DEFINITELY HIGHLIGHTED SOME
ONGOING ISSUES FACING- STUDENTS
THAT ARE IN OUR VARIOUS HIGHER
EDUCATION- INSTITUTIONS. SO WE
SAW A NEED AN INCREASED NEED
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
INTERNET AND TECHNOLOGY ACCESS
TO ADDRESS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED A
FIFTEEN MILLION I'M ONGOING
GENERAL FUND TO THIS YES YOU
FOR THESE PURPOSES. WELL THEN
JUST FOR THE RECORD MY QUESTION
WAS WHY IT COMBINED. BUT NOT
THAT WE DON'T QUESTION WE
SUPPORT OF THE NEED FOR EACH
ONE BUT IT SORT OF MAKES THEM
COMPETE AGAINST EACH OTHER
RATHER THAN SAYING THIS IS A
GOAL WILL SET ASIDE A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO MEET IT. AND
THIS IS A SECOND GOAL AND WILL
SET A CERTAIN SET OF. AMOUNT OF
MONEY TO MEET IT BECAUSE THERE
COULD BE SOME PLACES WHERE. OF
THE TECHNOLOGY NEED IS SO HIGH
AND APPROPRIATELY SO WITHIN
MENTAL HEALTH GET SHORTED
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T VIEW THAT
AS A PRIORITY SO I WOULD JUST
OFFER THAT AS A CONSIDERATION
AS YOU HEAD TOWARD THE MAY
REVISE. OF MY OTHER TWO
QUESTIONS ARE FOR THE CSU
SYSTEM. IN THE FIRST ONE IS
THAT- I HAD A COLLEAGUE
YESTERDAY ON YOUR BEHALF RATHER
VEHEMENTLY TELL ME HOW
SUCCESSFUL YOU HAD BEEN. IN
RAISING THE PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS THAT GRADUATED IN FOUR
OR FOUR YEARS THAT- YOU'D
RAISED BY AT LEAST TEN PERCENT.
AND THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS AT THE
HEART OF THAT WAS JUST GOING TO
ASK YOU. ARE GIVEN THE
PROPOSALS IN THE BUDGET WHAT
HOW DOES THAT SET AGAINST. YOUR
CONTINUING TO MAKE PROGRESS ON
THE GRADUATION. INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. WELL I
THINK ALSO OFF THE CENTERS
RANGE AGAIN FROM ISSUE. I THINK
ONE THING IS IN JEOPARDY
INSTEAD BEFORE ENABLED HER TO
SUSTAIN THAT THAT INCREMENTAL
FUNDING THAT WE PUT IN PLACE
NOW FOR. FOR A SIX YEAR TIME
FRAME SO WHAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED
HERE IS WITH THE GRANT
INITIATIVE TO BE A SIX YEAR
INCREMENTAL INCREASE OF ON
GOING FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
INITIATIVE. AND SO FAR THE
STATE HAS BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE
IN THAT WE'VE WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO USE BOTH TUITION REVENUE AS
WELL AS A STATE GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT. TO REALLY COVER MOST
OF THE- REESE. BUT CHALLENGE
BEEN IN TWENTY TWO ONE. WITH IT
WITH THE BY CUTS THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS- WE ARE. VERY
OPTIMISTIC OF COURSE THAT ALL
OF WHAT WE GOT IN IN IN TERMS
OF ARE EVER GOING FORWARD IN
TERMS OF RECRUITING STUDENTS
TAKE MORE UNITS. BEING ABLE TO
USE A LOT OF THIS BASIC NEEDS.
INITIATIVE SORTS OUT OF POCKETS
OF FUNDING IS GOING TO PAY
DIVIDENDS OVER THE LONG HAUL
THE ONE THING THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS IF THAT
RESTORATION DOES NOT OCCUR- AND
IF AGAIN IN IN TWENTY TWO.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IF
THERE'S SAY THE LANDING POINT
IS ONLY THAT ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN
POINT FIVE. WE DO FEEL LIKE
THAT SOMETHING THAT IS THAT WE
WOULD BE IN JEOPARDY ONE OTHER
THING THAT WOULD MAKE WANT TO
MENTION AND IT GOES BACK TO
ISSUE NUMBER ONE BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT. IS THAT
THE FEDERAL FUNDS ARE ONLY
AVAILABLE FOR ONE YEAR. BOTH
THAT MONEY THAT WAS WAS ADDED
BY CURES ACT BACK IN- MARCH
APRIL TIME FRAME AS WELL AS
THIS NEW TRUNCHEON MONEY. ADDED
BY THE CURSOR APPROPRIATION IN
DECEMBER SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT IN ORDER TO
SUSTAIN. THE GRADUATION IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE
TO MARCH FORWARD WITH EVEN
BETTER GRADUATION RATES AND
BETTER SUPPORT OF STUDENTS.
THAT WE DON'T FALSELY COME TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT FEDERAL
FUNDING WILL SUPPORT THE
UNIVERSITY LONGER TERM WHAT
REALLY IS NECESSARY YES ONGOING
FUNDING THAT CAN. CAN CAN
BASICALLY SUPPORT THE FACULTY
AND STAFF THAT WILL BE
DELIVERING THOSE INSTRUCTIONAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS SUPPORT
SERVICES TO STUDENTS. AND THEN
LET ME COMMENT ON YOUR ANSWER
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THE FIRST
PART. ON THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE. FOR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THE RELEASE. THE IF YOU
DO HAVE. CONSISTENT BASE
FUNDING IT TO PASS LEVEL OVER
TIME THAT'S GOING TO BE
THREATENED AS A GOAL I HEARD
THAT CLEARLY EVEN IF YOU DIDN'T
SAY IT THAT'S A SINGLE. AND
THEN SECONDLY OF SPEAKING TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I
KNOW HOW YOU GUYS FREQUENTLY
THANK IT AND YOU'RE SITTING
HERE WORRIED ABOUT OUT HERE
DEFICITS AND THAT IF YOU ADD
THE BASELINE. BACK IN- YOUR
ADDING TO THE OUT YEAR DEFICITS
BUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO GO
TO THAT BASELINE AT SOME POINT.
PREFERABLY THIS YEAR ARE TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT CSU CAN
MEET THESE NEEDS AND SO I JUST
HOPE THAT AS YOU MOVE TOWARD
THE MAY REVISE. DO YOU EALLY
CONSIDER THAT BECAUSE THAT
REALLY ALLOWS ALL THE OTHER
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN BUDGETED
FOR TO ACTUALLY BE USED FOR
THAT WITH AN INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT SUPPORTS THEM. AND THEN
ONE LAST QUESTION FOR CSU. IF
THE EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID
FUNDS ARE APPROVED HERE HOW YOU
ADMINISTER THEM HOW OR WHAT'S
YOUR PROCESS FOR GETTING THEM
OUT TO PEOPLE. IT'S AGAIN THIS
IS NATHAN EVAN I'M NOT WASN'T
SURE IF MY COLLEAGUE RYAN
STRONG WAS GOING TO STATUS STEP
IN ARE NOT KNOW WE'RE HAVING
FUN TECHNOLOGICAL ISSUES WERE
PUT TO ONE OF YOU UP ALL THE
OTHER ONE TALKS AND- IF YOU
EVER WANTED TO PUT WORDS IN
RAIMES MOUTH. THIS IS THE TIME.
WAY TO DO IT I UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THAT- WELL THANK YOU
ITS IT'S- EXCELLENT QUESTION
AND I THINK WE- AS I BRIEFLY
MENTIONED- IN MY COMMENTS. WE
HAD A NAY- WE'VE HAD NOW THE
EXPERIENCE LAST SUMMER OF
AWARDING OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
DIRECTLY TO STUDENTS IN VERY
SHORT ORDER THAT CAME THROUGH
THE FEDERAL CARES ACT. AND THE
FIRST- HERE OF- DOLLARS THAT
WERE APPROVED. AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL- WE APPROACH THAT AND AT
THE TIME WAS OF THE ESSENCE AS
IT IS A CONTINUES TO BE TODAY
AND ENSURING THAT STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES HAVE THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY NEED. TO CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION WE APPROACH
THAT IN A THREE PHASE OR THREE
TIERED PROCESS WORKING WITH OUR
CAMPUSES WHERE- WE LOOKED AT
DOCUMENTED NEED TO THAT
STUDENTS HAD EVEN PRE PANDEMIC.
AND PRIORITIZING THE STUDENTS
WITH THE GREATEST NEED FOR
EXAMPLE THOSE WITH ZERO
ESTIMATED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION
TO RECEIVE OF THE LARGER SHARE
A SECOND WAVE WAS FOR THOSE
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES KIND OF
AND THEN IN THE MID TIER WITH
SOME NEED. AND THEN THE THIRD
WORK WORK FOR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES THAT PERHAPS PRE
PANDEMIC HAD NOT BEEN.
RECIPIENTS OF FEDERAL OR STATE
OR INSTITUTIONAL AID HOWEVER
GIVEN THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC HAD HAD SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES AND THEIR FANS- FAMILY
FINANCIAL SITUATION. SO WITH
THAT EXPERIENCE AND LEARNING I
THINK WE WOULD TAKE A SIMILAR
APPROACH PRIORITIZING THOSE
STUDENTS WITH THE GREATEST
NEED- AS A MISS KING MENTIONED
PART OF IT WILL ALSO BE
DEPENDED ON WHAT'S- OR
COORDINATED POTENTIALLY WITH.
THE FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT ARE
COMING FORWARD AND WORK THEY
WERE APPROVED IN DECEMBER AS WE
SEE ANY SPOT SPECIFIC.
LIMITATIONS OR REQUIREMENTS OF
THAT FUNDING AND OUR HOPE WOULD
BE THAN TO COORDINATED THIS
FUNDING THE STATE FUNDING TO
EITHER IDENTIFY AND TARGET
STUDENTS THAT PERHAPS WERE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR. THAT FIT THOSE
FEDERAL DOLLARS OR TO AUGMENT
THOSE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
WITH THEIR THE MOST ARE THE
GREATEST NEED. THANK YOU WHAT
WILL BE INTERESTED TO JUST SEE
HOW. THAT UNFOLDS OVER TIME. A
NOW QUITE. FOR OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THERE ANY. FROM
SENATOR OCHO BOOK ARE NOT ANY
QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR MATH I
JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION- AND
JUST PICKING UP ON- WOULD TO
USE YOU JUST WAS STATING- WE
HAVE A DECEMBER STIMULUS BUT
THERE IS ALSO UNDER WAY RIGHT
NOW- A NOTHER STIMULUS PACKAGE
THAT IS IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
HEADED. TOWARDS PASSAGE- THE
AREA AND I GUESS THE QUESTION
IS YOU KNOW I FULLY SUPPORT THE
PRIORITIES OUTLINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HERE- YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO HELP LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO ADDRESS
FOOD INSECURITY HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH- AND TECHNOLOGY GAPS-
THESE ARE ALL IMPORTANT
PRIORITIES BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS. GIVEN THAT WE HAVE
ANOTHER TROTTER OF MONEY
COMING- AND WE DON'T YET KNOW
HOW THAT'S GONNA BE ALLOCATED
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO MAYBE
HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY AND
DISCRETION GIVEN THE CSU'S AND
HOW TO USE THESE FUNDS TO IT TO
TRY TO REALLY FILL IN THE GAPS
THAT THEY MIGHT SEE. AS OPPOSED
TO SEILING. USING INSIDE
POCKETS. I AND I GUESS THIS IS
A DEPARTMENT FINANCING LA- TELL
ADAM YEAH AS YOU'RE AWARE WE
WERE DEFINITELY NOT I'M NOT
AWARE OF THAT THE MOST RECENT-
YOU KNOW CREDIT HOURS RELEASE.
FINDING IT WAS PROVIDED IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY INTO
YOUR POINT IN THE OTHER THERE
MAY BE OTHER FINDS COMING- THAT
SAID I THINK THE STUDENTS- ARE
STILL FACING A GREAT DEAL OF
NEED- IN LIGHT OF COME IN THE
COMING NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND SO
IF WE SEE AN EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL. AID AS A WAY TO
CONTINUE ACTIVELY PROVIDING
ACCESS TO THE CSU- AND OUR
OTHER HIGHER. EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. JUST A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION THERE A- TOO MANY
LIMITS THIS IS FOR THE SAKE
ARGUMENT THERE IS A LAW MORE
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PURPOSE OF- EMERGENCY SUPPORT
FOR FINANCIAL AID FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. WOULD YOU BE
OPEN LATER ON TO REVISED AT
CHANGING THIS REQUEST AND
PERHAPS- GIVING THE CSU SOME
DISCRETION HOW TO USE IT. YEAH
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH FINANCE I
THINK IT'S A BIT TOO EARLY TO
YOU KNOW SPECULATE ON THE
DECISIONS THAT WE WOULD MAKE-
REGARDING THAT THOSE FUNDS IF
AND WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOES MAKE THEM AVAILABLE TO THE
CSU. SO WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
COMMENT AS TO WHAT WE WOULD
PLAN TO DO WITH THE EXISTING
RESOURCES HOWEVER. YOU KNOW
RIGHT WE DO PUT FOR THOSE
RESOURCES FOR OUR STUDENTS AND
WHEN YOU PUT THE BOARD IN WHAT
WE BELIEVE. TO BE A VERY
FLEXIBLE WAY FOR CAMPUSES TO
PROVIDE THOSE REACHED. TOWARD
THIS IS. A TO SOME OF OUR
NEEDIEST STUDENTS IN STATE. SO
WE DO PROVIDE A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY TO KEEP ITS IS AND
HOW THEY ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM.
THANK. THE COMPLETE YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR MEANT. GREAT
THEN WE WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE WHICH IS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND WE HAVE THE
SAME THREE PANELISTS IN THE
SAME THREE. SAME PORTER AND SO
WE'LL START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. ARAMBULA BRANDS
AGAIN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION PLANS FIND GENERAL
FUND. SPENDING STRINGY WILL THE
CS HERE TO ADDRESS CRITICAL
DEFERRED MEGAN'S NEEDS HAS BEEN
PREVIOUSLY STATED THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS YES YOU ARE
SIGNIFICANT AND RESOURCES WILL
HELP PROLONG THE LIFESPAN OF
THE SYSTEM'S CAMPUSES AND
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
STARK. AND AGAIN SENATOR- I
WOULD LIKE TO DO FOR MY TO MY
CALL VICE ONE. SHE HAS THE
GREAT EXPERTISE ON OUR CAPITAL.
PROGRAM THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CARE LAYERED AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AS BRIAN MENTIONED
I'M BY SEN ONE ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR CAPITAL PLANNING
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION FOR THE
SAME ISSUE. WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN TO EXPAND THE
CSU'S ACCORDING TO FINANCE AND
FUND CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT AND SINCE
HE WAS HEAVILY RELIANT ON VOTER
APPROVED GENERAL OBLIGATION
BONDS. WHICH HAVE NOT PASSED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX AND TO A
LESSER EXTENT PUBLIC WORKS
BOARD BONDS APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE SO THE INCREASED
AUTHORITY IN THE RIGHT AT THE
STATE REALLY VERY HELPFUL THE
IT SEEMS. TO SERVE OUR
STUDENTS. WITHIN THIRTY THE CSU
IS PRIORITIZE RENEWAL AND
IMPROVEMENTS TO CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PARTICULARLY
THOSE PROJECTS WHICH WOULD
ENSURE THE CAMPUS WOULD NOT BE
SHUT DOWN FROM REACH UTILITY
POINT OF VIEW OR CRITICAL
BUILDINGS. WE DRESS SIZE
EXTRACTING ADDRESS START
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
AND WE REALLY HAVE DONE LIMITED
NEW FACILITIES TO SERVE
ADDITIONAL MEANT. ADAM
RELATIVELY NEW CAMPUSES ST
CHANNELS IN MONTEREY BAY. THE
AUTHORITY HAS ENABLED MORE THAN
TWO BILLION TO BE REINVESTED
INTO CSU TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES.
IN THE MULTI YEAR PLAN THAT
WENT BEFORE THE BOARD IN THIS
THIS LAST NOVEMBER THE CAMPUSES
OF IDENTIFIED NEED OF OVER
SIXTEEN MILLION SO TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF NEED AND WE
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSED HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. CRISTINA
SUIT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PRIORITIES. THE FUNDS WOULD
HELP ENSURE THE CSU CAMPUSES
CONTINUE TO OPERATE DURING
EXPECTED AND UNEXPECTED POWER
SHUT DOWNS AND RENEW AGING
FACILITIES. MANY OF THE
VENTILATION AND LIGHTING
REPLACEMENTS. WOULD REDUCE
ENERGY CONSUMPTION. FOR THE
DEPRIVE ON. BOARD OF TRADE.
CARBON REDUCTION GOAL. WE
FLEXIBLE IN THE OF THE PHONE TO
DRAW DEFERRED. AS WELL AS
IMPROVEMENTS AS WAS PROVIDE IN
THE CURRENT YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AS WE ADDRESS CHILD CARE
FACILITIES. THE SYSTEM OFFICE
HELPS CAMPUSES BY SETTING UP
MASTER CONTRACTS AND AGREEMENTS
THAT HELP STREAMLINE CAMPUS
CONTRACTING IN ORDER TO GET
PROJECTS GOING AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
WOULD GENERATE ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND SIXTY JOBS BOTH
INDIRECT AND DIRECT JOBS. THIS
IS YOUR REQUESTED ONGOING BASED
BUDGET FUNDING FIFTEEN MILLION
MESS RAIMES STORM MENTION TO
ADDRESS FACILITY RENEWAL. AND
THAT WOULD HAVE DRIVEN ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED TO NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE PROJECTS FUNDING. SO
AS IS MENTIONED IT'S. LESS THAN
WHAT WE REQUESTED. IT TO DRESS
TOTAL NEED VETERANS FIVE AND IN
ONE TIME FUNDING. IS MORE THAN
THE FIFTEEN. AND IN REQUESTED
ON. BASED BUDGET NEEDS SERVICE
BRIAN MENTIONED BASE BUDGET
FUNDING CERTAINLY GIVES GREATER
PLANNING. TO LOOK AT A MULTI
YEAR PROGRAM. WE HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROJECTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED IN HIGHER
BUDGET CYCLES THAT SHOULD THE
L. WILL FUNDING BE RELEASED
EARLIER WE CAN GET GOING ON
THOSE PROJECTS. AND APPRECIATE
ANY FUNDING BEYOND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO ADDRESS
THE SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE CITY'S NEEDS ACROSS CSU.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO OF
LISA CAME FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. OKAY AS OUR
OFFICES SAID IN THE PAST WEEK
LEAVE THAT MONEY DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS THAT PRUDENT USE
OF ONE TIME FUNDS. IT IS FOR AN
EXISTING APPLICATION THAT COULD
IMPACT GROW IN THE OUT YEARS IF
SHE'S NOT ADDRESS NOW. FOR THAT
REASON WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDE AT LEAST A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME THAT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES FOR THIS PURPOSE. TO
THE EXTENT THAT IT CAN FREE UP
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME FUNDS FROM
OTHER INITIATIVES THAT COULD
EVEN CONSIDER PROVIDING MORE
ONE TIME CONSTRICTING MINTS. WE
DO A ONE RECOMMENDED
MODIFICATION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE REQUIRE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH PROJECTS ARE
BEING SUPPORTED BY THE FUNDS
THIRTY DAYS AFTER THE FUNDS ARE
RELEASED. WE WOULD RECOMMEND
INSTEAD REQUIRING NOTIFICATION
THE LEGISLATURE BEFORE THE
RELEASE OF THE FUNDS. JUST A
LOT MORE MEANINGFUL LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF NOW WILL MOVE TO
QUESTIONS AND- I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION MAYBE ALL DIRECTED TO
THE CSU REPRESENTATIVE BUT- IT
SAYS IN A REPORT TO A NUMBER OF
THESE PROJECTS ARE FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEASURES IF THIS IS
APPROPRIATED IT AND THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS ARE
IMPLEMENTED WILL THIS MEAN YOUR
UTILITY BUDGET WILL GO DOWN IN
FUTURE YEARS OF THAT MONEY
MIGHT BE AVAILABLE FOR SOME OF
THE OTHER THINGS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IN THIS HERE. YES
SENATOR LAYERED IT WOULD ALLOW
OUR UTILITY BUDGETS TO BE
REDUCED THE OTHER AREA WE'RE
TARGETING IS TO BE ABLE TO USE
THE DOLLARS AS MATCHING FUNDS
TO LEVERAGE SOME UTILITY
GRANTS. SO THAT IS ONE OF THE
APPROACHES WE'VE TAKEN OVER
TIME THE MULTI YEAR. ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PARTNERSHIP WITH
LOCAL UTILITIES SO THERE'S TWO
FULL BENEFIT TO USING THE FUNDS
FOR ENERGY IMPROVEMENTS. I
APPRECIATE THAT AND DO YOU IT
JUST OCCURS TO ME- BECAUSE A
NUMBER OF YOUR- CAMPUSES ARE IN
AREAS COVERED BY. COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATION CCA'S. DO
YOU TO YOUR CAMPUS IS SIGNED UP
WITH THAT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THAT'S 325% CHEAPER IN UTILITY
COSTS. RIGHT WHAT WE HAVE I'D
LIKE TO SAY ELEVEN CAMPUSES ON
DIRECT ACCESS BUT YOU YOU MAY
KNOW THAT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
HAVE MORE CAMPUSES ADDED TO
DIRECT ACCESS. SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT FORMING A COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATION COMMITTEE
CHOICE ENERGY DONE SOME INITIAL
WORK IN HOUSE CONSULTANTS
HELPING US ON THAT AND
SOMETHING WE HOPE TO PURSUE
THIS NEXT YEAR SO IT IS A
ACTIVE ACTIVITY WHILE IF YOU-
NEED SOME HELP PLEASE. BE TOUCH
WITH THE COMMITTEE I KNOW THAT
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN I WAS IN
THE LEGISLATURE BEFORE I DID A
BILL. THAT ALLOWED LOCAL
ENTITIES TO GENERATE ENERGY AT
ONE LOCATION AND MOVE IT
THROUGH THE GRID TO POWER THEIR
FACILITIES IN ANOTHER LOCATION
AND I THINK SOMEBODY DID A BILL
AFTER I LEFT TO EXPAND IT TO
SEE ISSUES. SO IF THERE'S
ANYTHING IN THAT ARENA- THAT
YOU NEED ASSISTANCE WITH PLEASE
LET US KNOW. THIS IS A TIME FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ASK QUESTIONS-
SENATOR MANY QUESTIONS CENTER
OCHO BOTH. OKAY ARE OF NO
QUESTION SIR WILL MOVE. TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. WHICH IS OUR
VARIOUS GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
BUDGET PROPOSALS AND WE HAVE
THE SAME PALACE IN THE SAME
QUARTER SO IT'S BEGIN WITH
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
RIANA BRANDS OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I THINK PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL IS A HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND. AND TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATIONS THIS
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING
PROPOSALS. TWO MILLION I'M
GOING GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
THE ADOPTION OF A COMMON INTER
SEGMENTAL LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. ONE MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
INCREASED FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS AT THE CSU STANISLAUS
STOCKTON CAMPUS. TEN MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE COMPUTING TALENT
INITIATIVE ADMINISTERED THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
MONTEREY BAY. AND FINALLY TEN
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT CULTURALLY COMPETENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
FACULTY. THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF CSU.
ANY COMMENTS ON THIS. YES VERY
BRIEF BY ME BRAINSTORM AND THEN
I WILL ASK MASON EVANS TO
PLEASE CHIME IN ON. US SOME
MORE DETAIL BUT GENERALLY
SPEAKING I THINK WHAT YOU SEE
IN THIS IN THIS. ITEM ISSUE
HERE IS A VARIETY OF. OF
SPECIFIC VERY SPECIFIC ITEMS TO
FOR THE C. ISSUE TO EMPLOY IF
THEY WERE APPROVED. I THINK ONE
THING GLOBALLY WHAT WE WOULD
SUGGEST IS TO PROVIDE US AS
MUCH FLEXIBILITY AS POSSIBLE IN
ACHIEVING SOME OF THESE GOALS
FOR EXAMPLE. ON THE LEARNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM OR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT I
KNOW. I KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION
SO FAR INDICATING THROUGHOUT
THIS ENTIRE AGENDA HAS PROVIDED
A GREAT DEAL OF FLEXIBILITY IN
TERMS OF OUR ABILITY AS
UNIVERSITY S. R. TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS. TO
ADJUST ACCORDINGLY WE
APPRECIATE THE GREAT BUT AS YOU
CONTINUE TO CONSIDER THESE AND
IF THESE ARE. ALTERNATELY
ADOPTED I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE
YOU TO MAINTAIN THOSE THOSE
LEVELS OF FLEXIBILITY. THE ONE
THING THAT I WILL MENTION ON
THE LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEM-
ONE THING THAT WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT A NAKED EVENTS WILL ALSO
PROBABLY HAVE SOME SOME
COMMENTS HERE TO. IS THAT WE
DO- WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE BEST
APPROACH HERE IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS A OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT- REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL OR RE REQUEST FOR
QUALIFICATIONS SORTS OF MODEL
HERE. WHAT THE SEGMENTS CAN
COLLECTIVELY GAIN GET THE BEST
BANG FOR THE BUCK FOR STUDENTS
OR STUDENTS USE AS WELL AS OUT
FOR ACADEMIC. PURPOSES SO I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE- THE
COMMITTEE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO REALLY JUST PROVIDE
THIS ALL THE SEGMENTS BECAUSE
THIS PROPOSAL. IS SISTER PLAYED
TO ALL BOTH COMMUNITY COLLEGES
YOU SEE AS WELL AS US. PROVIDE
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO I JUST DO
A BONAFIDE OUR OUR P. R. F. Q.
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN GET THE
BEST. PRODUCT FOR OUR STUDENTS
IN THE LONG TERM. AND. ANYTHING
HAPPENS PLEASE. YES I THINK YOU
MISTER VERY BRIEFLY- IF ON THE
PROGRAMMATIC- A TOP. PERSONAL
MANAGE SO. I WOULD- J. THAT FOR
NUMBER YEARS SINCE THE ISSUES
MAINTAIN. CENTRAL NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS FOR A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS ARE REALLY LEVERAGES
SIZE AND SCALE OF THE OUR
UNIVERSITY. FOR FAVORABLE
PRICING- AND FORTY AS IS NOTED
IN THE REPORT FOR TODAY
FOURTEEN OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE
GRAVITATED TO ONE SYSTEM WITH
THE BALANCE OF OUR CAMPUSES ON
OTHER PLATFORMS. AND SEVERAL OF
THOSE REMAINING NINE HAVE
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN MOVING TO
THE MORE UBIQUITOUS PLATFORM-
AND THESE RESOURCES CERTAINLY
COULD HELP FACILITATE THOSE
TRANSITIONS- BUT I WOULD ECHO
MISTER STORMS COMMENTS I HAD. A
CONCERN WE WOULD EXPRESS IS
REGARDING THE INCLUDE THE
POTENTIAL INCLUSION OF ANY
PROPRIETARY ENERGY AND BUDGET
LANGUAGE WE WANT TO BE MINDFUL
THAT TECHNOLOGY EVOLVES VERY
QUICKLY. AND WE CERTAINLY DON'T
WANT TO CREATE A SITUATION
WHERE WE ARE NOT RECOGNIZING
THE POTENTIAL FOR- TECHNOLOGY
OBSOLESCENCE. IN ANY PRODUCT OR
OR SERVICE SO THAT WOULD BE ONE
PIECE OF FEEDBACK. REGARDING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FACULTY-
WE'VE SEEN THE PROMOTION OF
INCLUSIVE EQUITY MINDED
TEACHING AND CURRICULUM. AS A
PRIMARY FOCUS OF FACULTY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IN THE
C. ISSUE IN RECENT YEARS. AND
THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC IS
REALLY AMPLIFIED THE AWARENESS.
OF THOSE IN AND OTHER EQUITY
ISSUES PARTICULARLY AROUND
STUDENTS ACCESS TO DEVICES
RELIABLE HIGH SPEED INTERNET.
AND THOSE OF ALL LEAD TO A
DEEPER CONCERN ABOUT EVERY
ASPECT OF INSTRUCTION FROM
THEIR- SELECTION OF COURSE
CONTENT TO HOW TO BEST
APPROACH- AND DESIGN LEARNING
ACTIVITIES AND THE CREATION OF
COMMUNITY. IN THE DIGITAL
SPACE. THESE RESOURCES
CERTAINLY WOULD ROVIDE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FACULTY DEVELOPMENT IN THIS
ARENA ALSO HOW HELPING
TRANSLATE IT BACK TO GREATER IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. AND I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT HIS SUMMER-
PAST SUMMER 60% OF CSU FACULTY
ENGAGED AND PROFESSIONAL THE-
THAT WAS A OVER HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND HOURS. OF FACTLY
DEVELOPMENTS- ENGAGEMENT REALLY
JUST TRYING TO ADDRESS- THE
MOVED TO VIRTUAL LEARNING- AT
WRIT LARGE BUT ALSO DOING SO IN
THE MOST EQUITABLE APPROACH
POSSIBLE SO THOSE ARE THE TWO
ITEMS THAT I JUST WANTED TO
BRIEFLY. TOUCH ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A NUMBER
MOVES THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. OKAY I MEAN
REPORT ON THE COMPANY'S MAJOR
UNIVERSITY PROPOSALS COVER IS
ONE OF THE PROPOSALS INCLUDING
THIS ISSUE. THAT FACULTY
THRESHOLD AMOUNT AND ONE. IN
REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL WE
BELIEVE THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
IDENTIFIED AN IMPORTANT AREA OF
FOCUS WHEN IT COMES TO
EXPANDING ONLINE EDUCATION. BUT
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL COULD
BENEFIT FROM PRINTING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT FOR EXAMPLE
LEGISLATURE ME WHICH NOW HOW
MANY FACULTY AT CSU CONTINUE TO
NEED SUPPORT WITH ONLINE
EDUCATION WHAT TYPES OF SUPPORT
THEY NEED. THE COST OF
PROVIDING NOT SUPPORTING WHAT
EXISTING RESOURCES INCLUDING
FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT. NUMBER ONE EARLIER
THIS MORNING THE RECOMMENDED
THE LEGISLATURE DROPSY SEALING
THE OTHER SEGMENTS REPORT
CERTAIN BASELINE DATA ON NLINE
EDUCATION. WE THINK THAT
INCLUDING THAT DATA COULD BE AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL FACULTY SUPPORT. WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WAIT UNTIL IT RECEIVES THIS
TYPE OF INFORMATION BEFORE
CONSIDERING ANY FUTURE BUDGET
WHETHER DEFINING AUTHENTICATION
FOR THIS PARTICULAR PURPOSE.
SHE DOES ALSO INCLUDE THREE
ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND SEE
IF YOUR MENTIONS PLANNING
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. IN TOWNSHIP
AS WELL AS IMMIGRANTS STOCKTON
CAMPUS. WE HAVE AWESOME INITIAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THESE PROPOSALS
AND IN THE COMING WEEKS WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP THEIR STAFF TO
SURELY LEARNED. THAT BEING SAID
OF THE SUB COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE
ARE ALSO HELPING ANSWER
QUESTIONS IN THESE WAS BASED.
ON A- THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. A NO CLUE. I JUST WANT TO
SAY CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
COMPUTING TOWN INITIATIVE I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT TO. OUR
ENTERPRISE BUT NO QUESTIONS
FROM SENATOR MAN ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM CENTER GROVE
TROUBLE. THERE ARE NONE SO THAT
COMPLETES OUR DISCUSSION OF THE
FOUR ISSUES BUT NOW WILL MOVE
TO THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY
THAT WANTS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL ON
SINCE THEY'RE NO SIDES TO KNOW
FOLKS. IT'S A ONE. OPPORTUNITY
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE FOUR.
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN OF DOING
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LIKES OF HEARINGS AND
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. I'M GOING
TO PASS THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC PROVIDING COMIC KEEP
THEIR REMARKS WITH IN ONE
MINUTE AND- ALSO. OF THEIR OWN
MAINTAINED DURING THE HEARING
AS CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE THEY ME
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE HEARING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. SO NOW WILL
GO TO ANY- WITNESSES AND I'LL
BEGIN BY ASKING IF THERE ARE
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THERE'S ONE
PLEASE MOVE TO THE A MICROPHONE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF YOU HAVE UP
TO A MINUTE TO WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SENATOR MY
NAME IS DAVID ME ASSURE ON THE
SUPERINTENDENT FOR THAT THE
HOME VALUE NEW SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. WE'RE HERE
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN OPEN FOR IN
PERSON LEARNING FOR TEN MONTHS
WITH. VERY LITTLE COMMUNITY
SPREAD LOBBYING BUT- IN LIGHT
OF THIS CONVERSATION SAYING THE
EMPHASIS ON. CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE TRANSFER. AND THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDATIONTHAT
K. TWELVE EDUCATORS. ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR FASTER
COMPLETION AN FSA ID. MY
RECOMMENDATION IS TO AS YOU
CONSIDER THE GENERAL BUDGET TO
LOOK AT CAREER DEVELOPMENT AND
PERSONAL FINANCIAL DECISION
MAKING. AS A KEY ASPECT TO
CONNECT COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAL
STATE AND K. TWELVE. TO STAVE
OFF THE ONE POINT SEVEN
TRILLION DOLLARS IN OUTSTANDING
FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN DEBT. THE
GOAL OF THAT OF OUR STUDENTS IS%
NOT TO HAVE A DEGREE BUT THEY
HAVE GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT UPON
COMPLETION OF K. TWELVE POST
SECONDARY. AND SO CAREER
DEVELOPMENT POSTSECONDARY
FINANCIAL DECISION MAKING.
UNIFYING K. TWELVE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND CAL STATE WOULD BE
A BENEFIT TO STUDENTS BUT ALSO
FOR GENERAL ECONOMY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND JUST FOR THE
REFERENCE. OF THE SUB COMMITTEE
TOGETHER WITH THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION HOW TO
COMPLETE HEARING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S SCHOOL REOPENING
PROPOSAL WHICH I THINK IS
AVAILABLE ONLINE BUT JUST FOR
YOUR REFERENCE. ANYONE ELSE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY. HELLO A LOOK TO
ROOM ONE TWELFTH IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THAT ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY. I'M STARING AT
AN EMPTY ROOM IN AN EMPTY
PODIUM SO- WE WILL MOVE TO
ANYONE THAT WISHES TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT- VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS OUR
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AND THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH DEADLINE NUMBER PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE ZERO TO MAKE A
COMMENT. ONE MOMENT WITH THE
CHAIRMAN. LIE NUMBER SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS PREFERRED YEAH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION. GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET IS A GOOD
STARTING POINT AND IF AT AT IT
INTERESTING ADMINISTRATION
STUDENTS AND OTHER BARGAINING
UNITS TO MOVE IT FORWARD AND
MAKE A COMPELLING CASE FOR THE
DISH MOVIE PACKED WITH US WITH
THE NAME. ADDRESS MAKE LIFE
WITH THE WITH THE RESOURCES WE
RECEIVE FROM THE STATE FOR
INSTANCE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL INCLUDES FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
AND TECHNOLOGY NEEDS. THE DATA
AND THE LIVED EXPERIENCE OF OUR
FACULTY BUT THE MOST AFFECTED
MECHANISM FOR INCREASING
AVAILABILITY OF QUALITY STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IF PAGE
NOT MINE AND- BACK ON. LOOKING
FOR YOU TO DIRECT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AT. I'M NOT
REALITY. OUR GOOD START THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS NOT.
EFFECTIVELY AND MANY CHALLENGES
WITH. AFTER JOIN US IN AB FOR
ADDITIONAL. THAT WOULD ELECT
BUT THE THIRD THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY APPRECIATE YOUR TEST-
MODERATE NEXT TO. NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN LINUM
FOURTEEN YEAH LINE IS ALL
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SURE LAYERED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
RODRIGUEZ I'LL BE HAPPY TO
EDUCATION TRUST WEST. WHILE WE
STAND BEHIND OUR STUDENTS
SUPPORTING THE GOVERNOR'S
THIRTY MILLION ONGOING- DOLLARS
FOR BASICALLY MENTAL HEALTH
DIGITAL EQUITY AS WELL AS THE
CURRENT EFFORT TO MODERNIZE THE
CONTRACT SYSTEM TO ENSURE
EQUITY AND ACCOUNTABILITY. NEXT
WE'RE EXTREMELY PORTABLE
OVERLOOKED WHEN SHORT I. WILL
HAVE THEIR TWELVE FIFTEEN IS
GOOD FASTER CHANGE. ACTOR
HELPED LEAD INCOME. AND LET
INCOME STUDENTS- IT'LL- WITH
YOU IN ABOUT AT CHECK WITH. WE
HAD UNANIMOUS BY DID NOT ALLOW
YOU ALL I PLEDGE YOU STAND
BROWN ABOUT THIS IF YOU CUANDO
MEETING. AND THE BURGUNDY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BOB I WOULD
JANUARY TRUSTING HIM THROUGH
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HAS
YET TO BE INFORMED ABOUT THE
DISTRICT IMPACT REPORT AND SEE
IF YOU ACTUALLY GO TO A LOOK AT
THIS WILL HAPPEN REGARDLESS OF
THEM UNDERSTAND. IMPACT THIS
WILL HAVE ON THE STUDENTS.
CALLER STATEWIDE I WILL BE
HAPPY TO RECHARGE YOUR OFFICE.
BY THE END OF TODAY WITH THE
LETTER ON THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOUR CALL- MODERATOR NO
CALLER. YES A TIME I NUMBER
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU-
GOOD MORNING SURE LAYERED AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS QUAN LIU AND I SERVED
AS THE VICE PRESIDENT
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION. AND ON BEHALF OF
THE A FEW STUDENTS WE ARE
PLEASED BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT REFLECTS
HIS BELIEF IN THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CSU SYSTEM. IT IS CLEAR
THAT STATE INVESTMENTS HAVE
YIELDED GREAT RESULTS FROM
INCREASING GRADUATION RATES TO
THE PORTABILITY OF OUR
UNIVERSIT SYSTEM BUT
CHALLENGES STILL EXIST LIKE
TACKLING STUBBORN EQUITY GAPS.
THESE CHALLENGES REQUIRE
CONTINUED INVESTMENT BY THE
STATE WE CAN TRULY ENSURE THAT
THE- SYSTEM IS EQUITABLY
PROVIDING ALL CALIFORNIANS WITH
A HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION AND
RESOURCES NEEDED FOR TIMELY
GRADUATION. STUDENTS WERE ALSO
PARTICULARLY HAPPY TO SEE THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDS ALLOCATED TO THE
COURTS YOU TO BASIC NEEDS AND
HOPE THAT THE STATE LEGISLATURE
ADOPT OR EXPAND UPON THIS
ALLOCATION. I DON'T THINK WE'LL
FOR GOVERNOR NEWSOM BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO SEE IF YOU STAND
UNITED IN OUR BELIEF THAT AN
ADDITIONAL. FUNDING IS
NECESSARY SO WE CAN ONLY FIND
AND CONTINUE PROGRESS I
GRADUATION THAT SHOULD HAVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THOUSAND
FOR A FULL RESTORATION OF THE
TWO HUNDRED NINETY NINE BILLION
DOLLARS CUT LAST YEAR I'M NOT
NO WE ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE THE RECURRING PLAN
AUGMENTATION BY THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE BILLION. FOR ONE
TIME FUNDS WERE UP IN THE BEGIN
TO WRAP UP YOU'RE A YOU'RE A
BIT. OVER A MINUTE SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH. YOUR MODERATOR. OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
MY NAME IS KATIE RISE AND I AM
A STUDENT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR A FULLY FUNDED CSU
AND FOR THE ON FILLING FUNDING
FOR BASIC NEEDS. MENTAL HEALTH
AND TECHNOLOGY RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS AT ALLOCATED IN THE
GOVERNOR JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL TOTALING THIRTY
MILLION. ALL OF THESE ISSUES
ARE CRITICAL PRIORITIES FOR CSU
STUDENT AT CSU STUDENT BUT LIKE
YOU SEE INVESTMENT AND CAL
GRANT REFORM TO ENSURE THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE IS
ACCOUNTED FOR NOT JUST TUITION
AND FEES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. LIE
NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
MORNING SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS ARENAS
AND I'M A STUDENT TEACHER
BAKERSFIELD AND CSU STUDENT
TRUSTEE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH
FRANCE'S PUNCH IN THE STATE
THIS YEAR SHE HAS INCREASE
AGGRESSION BY 63% AND TODAY I
STAND WITH ALL THE ISSUE BUDGET
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE SHARED
BELIEF THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IF NECESSARY PLEASE CONSIDER
THE RECURRING FUND AUGMENTATION
INCREASED BY THIRTY THREE TO
GET A MILLION AN INCREASED
AMOUNT OF ONE TIME FUNDS I FIVE
AND THIRTY ONE MILLION. I LIKE
ESPECIALLY HIGHLIGHT ON
INCREASE. AND ALSO TRYING
TEMPORARILY INTEGRATED I CAN
ALSO ATTEST THAT HE SHOULD BE
HAS HELPED ME IMMENSELY AND I
WHEN I WENT HOME ISN'T AN JUNE
GET A CO THAT I WAS ABLE TO
FIND TEMPORARY HOUSING BERMAN
THAT HE SHOULD BE DARNED AND
YET HOW FRESH YOUR CAMPUS THE
LARGEST ALL MY HOUSING AND FOOD
SECURITY BUT THE ISSUE HAS BEEN
A LOT OF MY LIFE AND I WOULD
LOVE FOR YOU TO PLEASE THAT WE
INCREASE ON THAT FUNDAMENTAL
ASIAN INCREASE. A ONE TIME NON
FUNDS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. AT THE
TIME AT THE TIME AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE APPRECIATE YOUR HELP
TODAY MODERATOR END. YOUR
PROVIDE ME JUST SAY- THANK YOU
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY BUT A FEW. MORE
ABLE TO TESTIFY OR DIDN'T GET
TO THE PHONE QUICK ENOUGH YOU
CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE. OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. BECAUSE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS- LET
ME ASK WHO LAST QUOTED THERE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE OTHER
SENATORS BEFORE WE CONCLUDE.
SEEING NONE I WOULD JUST THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR PATIENCE AND
THEIR COOPERATION TODAY. THIS
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING AND THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE IS A JERK.